the India outlook 2012 session went off
quite well we had six finalists and they
are from diverse fields from private
equity ranging from private equity to US
Treasury to investment banking and so on
yes there are concerns at this point
because Indian economy there are
strengths on it economy is slowing and
interest rates are high and inflation is
high but there is a consensus among all
the panelist among all six panelists is
that the indian store is still intact
the long term story is still intact and
they have picked up certain segments
where which can attract investments
which are the interesting areas for
instance and anything and everything
which is where consumers are involved
for you soon retail apparels media there
have been talks about e-commerce
infrastructure so on and so forth so yes
there are temporary briefs but where
else you get an economy which is growing
at seven percent on around
so there is no worry for investors they
should stay invested or bring in more
money